Sensei, thank you for your time today.
Thank you for having me.
Sensei, how did you first learn about Daito-ryu?
When I was a high school student, I studied Chinese martial arts and Yagyu Shingan-ryu.
That master had also studied Daito-ryu under Yamamoto Kakuyoshi Sensei.
So, I learned a little bit of Daito-ryu as well from him.
At that time, one of my acquaintances told me about an interesting form of jujutsu and he introduced me.
So I went to see a class and this is how it began.
The place we visited was a dojo of Horikawa sensei’s Daito-ryu Aiki Jujutsu.
It was a student of Horikawa sensei who was teaching.
Since I was already doing Daito-ryu Jujutsu I wanted to try the class and the teacher let me grab his wrist.
And then, when I grabbed his hands, I got thrown.
The way how he threw me was very different compared to the Jujutsu I had trained.
The difference was that Jujutsu is mainly to lock the joints and throw, however, as I grabbed him I was thrown suddenly.
It was a very unusual feeling,
nothing like any technique I have experienced since then.
I was very surprised.
At that moment, I realized for the first time that such techniques exist in the world.
I wanted to become able to these techniques and enrolled in the dojo in July 1988.
That's how I joined Horikawa sensei’s Daito-ryu line.
Have you encountered any particular difficulty during your study of Daito-ryu?
It would be too much to say struggle,
but at the point when I had been training in Daito-ryu for 21 years,
in 2004
My sempai, who was teaching in Tokyo decided to become independent.
So it happened that the Tokyo dojo was left to me.
I found myself in a position where I had to teach others.
I felt the necessity to relearn the basics one more time.
I visited the home of Shimbo Tasuo Shihan in Sapporo, who is a Menkyo Kaiden Shihan of the Horikawa line.
I asked him if he would teach me.
In the beginning, he trained me together with three of his student from Sapporo.
I insisted to learn one-to-one and eventually he started to teach me privately.
He is a Menkyo Kaiden Shihan of Horikawa sensei and he started to give me private lessons.
On the first day, when I tried to apply a technique to Shimbo sensei, it didn’t work at all.
"Who did you learn from?" he asked.
"It’s totally wrong." he scolded me.
I still remember the shock.
I remember being shocked by the sound,
At the same time, receiving his techniques I did not doubt that his skill is real.
That was the moment I decided to throw away everything I had learned and restart from the basics.
And since that time, I was receiving his private lessons.
Receiving private teaching must have been a valuable experience.
Yes it has.
Could you tell us more about what and how you learned from Shimbo sensei?
The training with Shimbo Shihan is one to one.
First, I learned Shimbo Shihan’s technique. For example, I grab both of his wrists and he applies a technique to me.
Then, I apply the same technique to Shimbo Shihan.
However, it was very difficult, right?
We would practice the same technique over and over until Shimbo Shihan said "fine" as signal that my technique was good enough.
When I was learning Aiki techniques from Shimbo Shihan the techniques looked very simple.
However the simpler it looks the more difficult it is.
I was challenged to figure out the fundamental mechanism of Aiki.
Shimbo sensei would throw me and then I would throw him.
When I could do the techniques it felt like being in Heaven.
When I couldn't do it it was like Hell.
While going back and forth from Hell to Heaven, I learned the techniques little by little.
In our training, I received teaching from the basic to the secret techniques, as well as weapon techniques.
Shimbo Shihan taught me all the techniques.
His private lessons lasted from 2005 to 2018. Approximately 12 years.
We stopped the training due to Shimbo Shihan’s illness.
In June of 2018, I was invited to Shimbo Shihan’s home.
As proof that he taught me all his knowledge he awarded me Menkyo Kaiden and pointed me as his successor.
From ancient times, Menkyo Kaiden is something that is given from master to student.
It is different from the dan system of recent years, that is given by an organization.
I heard you got independent and created a new association last year. Could you tell us more about your new association?
It’s called Daito-ryu Aikijujutsu Koshinkai.
Referring to that we transmit Horikawa Kodo sensei’s techniques and spirit sincerely, I choose the name Koshinkai.
About Aiki, it takes a lot of time to require this skill.
My teaching style is to teach thoroughly so the Aiki techniques can be learned quickly.
Along the training process, together with the dan certificates, we give copies of scrolls transmitted from Takeda Sokaku sensei to Horikawa Kodo sensei.
Please tell us about the technical system.
Yes
Aiki is a way of using the body and it takes time to learn.
First, we teach the basic training method of how to develop Aiki.
Next, we train how to remove the grasp of the partner. It’s called ”Hazushite”.
Then come to the Jujutsu techniques.
The Jujutsu techniques are structured to serve as a base for the Aiki techniques.
After that, we focus on the Aiki techniques.
First the jujutsu techniques change into Aiki techniques.
Then, at a higher level, practitioners learn how to apply Aiki through weapons.
This is very difficult.
In general, Aiki-age is famous. However, in the Horikawa line, we learn many types of Aiki.
Then, at a higher level, practitioners learn how to apply Aiki through weapons.
I would like the next generation to take over these techniques taught by Horikawa sensei to Shimbo sensei.
I’m very afraid that these techniques would get lost.
Next time, please tell us about the history and techniques of Horikawa sensei.
Thank you very much for today.
Thank you.